♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
ONE OF THE ENVIRONMENTAL
CATASTROPHES OF OUR TIME IS
UNFOLDING TONIGHT OFF THE COAST
OF DENMARK.
THE NORTHERN STREAM PIPELINES,
RUSSIAN OWN CONDUITS TO TRANSFER
GASP, HAVE BEEN BREACHED.
THEY'RE POURING MILLIONS OF
CUBIC METERS OF GAS INTO THE
BALTIC SEA.
THERE'S A TOXIC BUBBLE FIELD
MORE THAN HALF A MILE WIDE.
YOU CAN ONLY GUESS HOW MANY
MARINE ANIMALS ARE BEING KILLED
RIGHT NOW, COUNTLESS.
BUT THE LASTING DAMAGE MAY BE TO
THE ATMOSPHERE.
IT'S 90% METHANE.
METHANE, AS BIDEN HAS TOLD US,
IS THE KEY DRIVER OF GLOBAL
WARMING, WHICH IS AN EXISTENTIAL
THREAT TO HUMANITY IN PLANET.
SO IF YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT
CLIMATE CHANGE, WHAT JUST
HAPPENED TO THE PIPELINES IS ITS
CLOSE OF THE APOCALYPSE AS YOU
CAN IMAGINE.
IT WASN'T AN ACCIDENT.
THE SAME TEN LEAKS WERE
DETECTED, THERE WERE TWO
UNDERSEA EXPLOSIONS, EACH OF
WHICH WAS EQUIVALENT TO HUNDREDS
OF POUNDS OF TNT.
NOTHING ON NATURE CAN ACCOUNT
FOR THAT.
LEAKS WERE IN THREE SEPARATE
PLACES.
ONLY ONE EXPLANATION.
THIS WAS AN ACT OF INDUSTRIAL
TERRORISM.
THAT WAS OBVIOUS TO THE
PRIME MINISTER OF POLAND AND HE
WASTED NO TIME SAYING SO.
>> TODAY, WE ARE ALSO DEALING
WITH AN ACT OF SABOTAGE.
WE DO NOT KNOW THE DETAILS OF
WHAT HAPPENED YET.
BUT WE CAN CLEARLY SEE THAT IS
AN ACT OF SABOTAGE.
AN ACT THAT PROBABLY MARKS THE
NEXT STAGE IN THE ESCALATION OF
THE SITUATION WE ARE DEALING
WITH IN UKRAINE.
>> Tucker: WE CAN CLEARLY SEE,
HE SAID, IT'S AN ACT OF
SABOTAGE.
WE CAN SEE THAT.
WHO DID IT?
PRIME SUSPECT IS OBVIOUS, HE
STOLE THE 2016 ELECTION FROM
HILLARY CLINTON, THAT WOULD BE
VLADIMIR PUTIN.
GOODEN IS THE NORTH STREAM
PIPELINE.
HE HAS DECIDED TO USE POLLUTION
AS AN ACT OF WAR, IT HAS BEEN
SAID.
TWITTER ENDORSE THAT POSITION.
PUTIN DID IT.
THAT MAKES SENSE!
POLLUTANT CAN BE EVIL, BUT IS HE
STUPID?
HE PROBABLY ISN'T STUPID.
AND YET, IF YOU'RE
VLADIMIR PUTIN, YOU'D HAVE TO BE
A SUICIDAL MODE ON TO BLOW UP
YOUR OWN ENERGY PIPELINE.
THAT'S ONE THING YOU NEVER DO.
NATURAL GAS PIPELINE IS THE MAIN
SOURCE OF YOUR POWER AND WEALTH
AND LEVERAGE.
EUROPE NEEDS YOUR ENERGY NO MORE
THAN EVER WITH WINTER
APPROACHING.
IF YOU CAN'T DELIVER THAT
ENERGY, THEN COUNTRIES LIKE
GERMANY HAVE NO NEED TO PAY
ATTENTION TO WHAT YOU WANT.
YOU'RE IN THE MIDDLE OF A WAR,
AND ALL HANDS ON DECK WORK.
SEEN IT ALL THE LEVERAGE YOU CAN
GET.
THERE IS NO CHANCE HE WOULD BLOW
UP NORTH NORTH STREAM ONE OR
TWO, NOT NOW, OBVIOUSLY.
EFFECTIVE SO OBVIOUS, OUR
FEBRUARY DIM SECRETARY OF STATE
TONY BLINKEN ACKNOWLEDGED IT.
HE SAID IT IS, CLEARLY AND NO
ONE'S INTEREST.
RIGHT.
BUT ONLY HALF RIGHT.
BLOWING UP NORTH STREAM DOESN'T
HELP PUT IN, HE WOULD NOT DO
THAT, WHY WOULD HE?
BUT THAT DOESN'T MEAN OTHER
COUNTRIES WOULD CONSIDER DOING
IT.
THEY HAD THEY HAVE CONSIDERED
WHEN I SAID SO IN PUBLIC.
IN EARLY FEBRUARY, BIDEN
SUGGESTED ON CAMERA THAT HE
MIGHT TAKE OUT THESE PIPELINES.
>> IF RUSSIA INVADES, THAT MEANS
TANKS OR TROOPS CROSSING THE
BORDER OF UKRAINE AGAIN.
THEN THERE WILL BE NO LONGER AN
NORTH STREAM TO.
WE'LL BRING IT INTO.
>> BUT HOW WILL YOU DO THAT?
CONTROL OF THE PROJECT IS WITHIN
GERMANY'S CONTROL.
>> I PROMISE YOU, WILL BE ABLE
TO DO IT.
>> Tucker: NOTICE HOW YOU
PHRASE THAT.
HE'S THE PRESIDENT.
HE DIDN'T SAY, I WILL PAUSE THE
DELIVERY OF GAS FROM RUSSIA TO
GERMANY.
HE SAID THERE WON'T BE A NORTH
STREAM TO.
WILL PUT AN END TO IT.
I WILL I WILL YOU DO THIS
MARQUIS WAS ASKED.
THEY THOUGHT THIS THROUGH.
THOSE WATCHING, INCLUDING US,
DIDN'T TAKE BIDEN SERIOUSLY WHEN
HE SAID IT.
HE DECLARED CLIMATE CHANGE THE
MOST PRESSING EMERGENCY IN THE
HISTORY OF THE WORLD.
HE LECTURES YOU ABOUT USING A
WOODSTOVE OR DRIVING AN SUV.
THIS IS THE GUYS SPENT BILLIONS
TRYING TO MITIGATE COW
FLATULENCE BECAUSE OF METHANE.
WITH THAT GUY BLOW UP A METHANE
PIPELINE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
BALTIC SEA?
THAT IT BE AN UNIMAGINABLY
RECKLESS ACT.
IF YOU WANT TO START A NUCLEAR
WAR, YOU WOULD DO THAT.
IT WOULD BE INSANE.
BUT THEY WERE THINKING ABOUT IT.
BIDEN WASN'T THE ONLY PERSON TO
SUGGESTED.
NEWLAND AT THE STATE DEPARTMENT,
A LIFE ON OR CHEERLEADER, HELPED
ENGINEER THE COUP THAT OVERTHREW
THE UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT,
CLEARLY SHE'S CAPABLE OF
ANYTHING, ENVIRONMENTAL
TERRORISM THOUGH?
EVEN PRETORIA NEWLAND, THAT
SEEMED TOO MUCH, TOO EXTREME.
AND YET HERE SHE IS IN JANUARY.
>> WITH A GO TO NORTH STREAM TO,
WE CONTINUE TO HAVE A VERY
STRONG AND CLEAR CONVERSATIONS
WITH HER GERMAN ALLIES, I WANT
TO BE CLEAR WITH YOU TODAY.
IF RUSSIA INVADES UKRAINE, ONE
WHERE AROUND THE, NORTHERN
STREAM TO WILL NOT MOVE FORWARD
>> Tucker: ONE WAY OR ANOTHER
WILL STOP NORTH STREAM.
THOSE WORDS SEEM CHILLING NOW.
YOU HAVE TO ASK, COULD THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION REALLY DO
SOMETHING LIKE THIS?
WE CAN SAY FOR SURE, WE DON'T
KNOW FOR SURE.
WE CAN TELL YOU THAT CLOSE
ALLIES OF THE BIDEN LIGHTHOUSE
BELIEVE THEY CERTAINLY DID DO
IT.
SIKORSKY IS A POLITICIAN,
CHAIRMAN OF THE PARLIAMENT,
HUSBAND OF VAN APPELBAUM OF THE
ATLANTIC MAGAZINE.
HE'S GOT A PICTURE IF HE AND
BIDEN TOGETHER IN THE TWITTER
PROFILE.
YOU RESPOND IMMEDIATELY.
THANK YOU USA.
SO ONCE AGAIN, TO THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION REALLY DO THIS
PUSH MARKETS HARD TO BELIEVE.
GIVEN THAT IT'S AN ATROCITY, IT
IS EFFECTIVELY AN ACT OF
TERRORISM, WE DON'T WANT TO MAKE
THAT ACCUSATION.
BUT WE SHOULD TELL YOU THAT,
MAYBE NOT ON COINCIDENTALLY, A
PIPELINE WAS ANNOUNCED.
THIS IS CALLED THE BALTIC PIPE,
INAUGURATED IN POLAND.
IT'LL CARRY NATURAL GAS FROM
NORWAY TO DENMARK AND POLAND AND
OTHER COUNTRIES NEARBY.
IT HAS LESS COMPETITION AND ALSO
DO WELL.
MAKING SENSE?
WHAT IS THE WHITE HOUSE SAY
ABOUT THIS?
HOW ARE THEY ACCOUNTED FOR WHAT
HAPPENED TODAY?
THEY'RE NOT EXCESSIVELY IN
ENTHUSIASTICALLY DENYING
RESPONSIBILITY.
THEY'RE LOOKING AT THE UPSIDE.
HERE'S THE PUBLICIST NOTING THE
DISK DESTRUCTION OF ANOTHER
PIPELINE IS ANOTHER OPPORTUNITY
FOR YOU TO BUY AN ELECTRIC CAR.
>> AS YOU ALL KNOW, THESE
PIPELINES WERE NOT PUMPING INTO
EUROPE AT THIS TIME.
IT WASN'T OPERATIONAL.
NS WANTED TO HAVE NOT BEEN
OPERATIONAL BECAUSE POLLUTANT
HAS WEAPONIZED ENERGY.
THIS JUST DRIVES HOME THE
IMPORTANCE OF OUR EFFORTS TO
WORK TOGETHER TO GET ALTERNATIVE
GAS SUPPLIES TO EUROPE, AND
REDUCE OUR DEPENDENCY ON GAS
CONSUMPTION AND MOVE TO CLEAN
ENERGY ECONOMY.
>> Tucker: OH.
MOVING TO CLEAN ENERGY.
SEE THE PEOPLE WHO MAY VERY WELL
BE RESPONSIBLE FOR LETTING
METHANE INTO THE BALTIC SEA AND
INTO THE ATMOSPHERE AT A SCALE
THAT MOST PEOPLE CAN IMAGINE.
THE PEOPLE LECTURING YOU ABOUT
YOUR SUV?
THEY HAVE BLOWN UP A NATURAL GAS
PIPELINE AND CREATED ONE OF THE
GREAT CATASTROPHES OF OUR TIME.
IN ITS EFFECT ON THE
ENVIRONMENT, IF THEY DID THIS,
THIS WILL BE ONE OF THE CRAZIEST
AND MOST DESTRUCTIVE THINGS ANY
AMERICAN ADMINISTRATION IS
OVERDONE.
BUT IT WOULD BE CONSISTENT.
ONE OF THE DO?
THEY DESTROY.
THEY DON'T BUILD ANYTHING,
INSTEAD THEY TEAR DOWN AND
DESECRATE, FROM STATUES TO
ENERGY INFRASTRUCTURE.
AND NO ONE IN CONGRESS IS TRYING
TO STOP ANY OF IT.
THEY'RE JUST PREPARING FOR THE
INEVITABLE FALLOUT.
THEY JUST ANNOUNCED A SPENDING
BILL TO RESPOND TO NUCLEAR
INCIDENTS IN UKRAINE.
THE SPENDING BILL ALSO BRINGS
THE TOTAL U.S. EXPENDITURE ON
UKRAINE, THE WAR BUT ALSO
FUNDING ITS GOVERNMENT AND
ENERGY FOR UKRAINE, TO
$67 BILLION ON THE EVE OF WHAT
COULD BE A MASSIVE ECONOMIC
DISRUPTION, HERE, TO OUR
ECONOMY.
$67 BILLION.
MORE THAN RUSSIA'S ENTIRE
MILITARY BUDGET LAST YEAR.
CONGRESS IS EXPECTED TO FULLY
PASS THE BILL, REPUBLICANS
NODDING ALONG WITH THE ZOMBIES
THEY ARE.
LITTLE BE THE EFFECTIVENESS?
EVERY ACTION HAS A REACTION,
EQUAL AND OPPOSITE.
BLOW UP THE NORTH STREAM
PIPELINES?
WE'VE ENTERED A NEW PHASE, ONE
IN WHICH THE UNITED STATES IS
DIRECTLY AT WAR WITH THE LARGEST
NUCLEAR POWER IN THE WORLD.
IT DOES SUGGEST THERE COULD BE
CONSEQUENCES.
IF WE BLOW UP THE NORTH STREAM
PIPELINE, WHY WOULDN'T RUSSIA
SEVER UNDERSEA INTERNET CABLES.
WHAT WOULD HAPPEN THEN PUSH MARK
WHAT IF EUROPEAN BANKS COULDN'T
COMMUNICATE WITH BANKS IN
NEW YORK?
LET'S JUST SAY THE BANKS
COULDN'T COMMUNICATE FOR EACH
OTHER FOR ONE DAY.
WHAT WOULD BE THE ECONOMIC
EFFECT OF THAT?
IT WOULD CASCADE DOWNWARD.
WE COULD HAVE AN ACTUAL
COLLAPSE.
WE COULD BE IN THIRD WORLD
CONDITIONS.
THOSE OF THE STEAKS.
AND THE PEOPLE BEH